so we're asked how many liters of soda
do we have for the party and they give
us all of this other information and so
what i encourage you to do is pause this
video and think about which of this
information you actually need to answer
this first question and then to try to
answer the question how many liters of
soda do we have for the party so pause
now
so let's look at this information 20
people are coming to the party but this
doesn't help us let us know how many
liters of soda we actually have so let's
we don't we can ignore this
we have purchased five bottles of soda
for the party well this seems useful so
we're gonna have five bottles of soda so
that's one
two
three
four
and five bottles of soda so that's
that's this piece of information right
over here we have purchased five bottles
of soda for the party if only we now
knew how much soda is in each bottle
now the other piece of information the
party will last for three hours well
this has nothing to do with how many
liters of soda we have
each bottle has two liters of soda now
this is interesting each bottle has two
liters of soda so this is 2 liters this
is 2 liters this is 2 liters this is 2
liters and that is 2 liters so if we
wanted to figure out the total number of
liters of soda that we have we have 5
bottles five bottles and each of them
are two liters each so we have five
times two and what is that equal to well
five times two is the same thing as two
plus two
plus two plus two you have five twos
added together so this is going to be
equal to let me write this down two plus
two plus two plus two plus two
which is equal to
two four six eight ten
five times two is ten we have ten liters
of soda for the party and we were able
to answer it without even looking at
this last one this last one tells us how
many bottles of soda we had for the
picnic last week which doesn't seem
related at all to our current party